so we've obtained exclusive body cam
footage from the police department in
westchester county new york the footage
shows about a hundred apparently illegal
immigrants mostly teenagers getting off
a charter flight in the middle of the
night in westchester the migrants then
get on buses someone on the tape
describes how quote dhs wants this on
the lowdown in other words secret so you
won't know about it despite the fact
you're a u.s citizen who is paying for
it they're hiding it from you they're
doing this without your consent speaking
of an attack on democracy
in the footage westchester police
express their frustration with what's
happening
are you trying to figure out what this
is yeah
yeah
so we've been having uh
you know
you're on a secure facility here and and
we don't really know anything we're in
charge of security
so that's hence where we're having a
problem here
so yeah we're hanging out here on the
tarmac like that
i don't know anybody pick up
uh i usually pick up basketball teams
that have more security yeah
yeah
and very easily you know
a few people could just go
that way
so i'm
it's slowly coming together
but we also don't know uh you know
really what's what's happening how
they're getting here whatever else
now just to be completely clear what you
just saw is illegal that's a crime
that's why they're keeping it secret the
us government is not allowed to abet the
breaking of federal law sorry
and that's exactly what they're doing in
the footage a government contractor
explains that the flights of illegal
immigrants arrive at smaller airports to
keep them hidden from the public
you don't want to be somewhere where
the spotlight yeah
down low is possible a lot of this is
just
no i get
don't it people because what we don't
want to do is attract attention we don't
want the media yeah like we don't even
know where we're going when they tell us
oh so just changing the population of
your country the one you were born in
but keeping it secret from you and then
attacking you with some kind of bigot if
you notice it that's the game have you
figured it out yet
well a different contractor offered his
explanation for why this all secret
i get the whole secrecy and all this
but this is even about my
yeah you know what i mean
[Music]
you know what i
mean and why
you know why you know what yeah i know
but why
yeah
no but what's what's the big secret
everybody knows it's happening
yeah the government is betraying the
american people that is true the biden
administration is changing this country
without your consent it's a crime and
it's immoral rob astorino is a former
westchester county executive he's
running for governor of the state of new
york he first obtained this body cam
footage through a foia request and we're
happy to have him join us tonight mr
estrino thanks so much for coming on i
mean that's evidence of a crime as far
as i can tell
our government is completely out of
control right now they have lied to us
they've lied to the american people
i saw what bill did last night down on
the southern border where
men are just getting into cabs and and
being put into communities that's what
they're doing here southern border
crisis they're waving them in they're
putting on planes sending them to
airports closed at night like
westchester putting them on buses and i
saw with my own eyes after they denied
it by the way
that they were put to uh onto a bus to a
costco and then released into cars into
the community now they keep saying it's
just unaccompanied kids completely a lie
and that these kids we're not going to
go into our own area completely alive
they're putting into schools in
westchester long island the surrounding
suburbs so it is a complete breakdown of
our system it is a betrayal as that
gentleman said a betrayal to the
american people and and of course when
i'm asking these questions when i broke
this in august
of course what do you think the response
was tucker you're a racist you're a
bigot you're a hater you're mean okay
answer the question when you're done
with that and they won't they deflect
and they lie continuously
so
you sort of i bless you for saying that
out loud you're not a racist most
americans are not it's the least racist
country in the history of the world so
at what point
do normal people democrats and
republicans say you're not going to
control me with that slur anymore answer
the question
well that's it we kept pressing them and
they kept telling us nonsense and this
is all they do right and where's
governor kathy hokel she's complicit in
this too
because she's turning a whole blind eye
to all of us it's happening right in our
communities in her state she's more
occupied about masking kids in schools
and coddling criminals than she is about
this now the public has a right to know
it's a public health issue we're under
our own orders in new york i can't go
into restaurants without showing a
vaccination card or masking you know in
doors
and she's refusing to do anything about
this
as people are coming in adults we have
no idea what their backgrounds are where
they're going where they're being placed
you know this is a public safety issue
but more than anything it's our own
government not telling us answers to our
questions and we're footing the bill on
all of this that's exactly right boy
that's so nicely put boy i hope you win
you have an unelected governor right now
well i hope people go to my twitter
account or any of my social media we're
going to put video up again right now
some more video and it's just totally
outrageous what is happening in this
country in new york and people and i'm
glad loudoun county and just normal
people are standing up right now and
saying enough is enough we're going to
take back our country all we want normal
people democrats republicans is for the
law to be enforced and to for people to
listen to us
it's so nice to hear a republican who
can actually explain himself which you
certainly can thanks for coming on the
show
thanks tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else